>>> ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU WHAT MIGHT
JUST BE THE MOST UNFORGETTABLE
CUP OF HOT CHOCOLATE THAT SOME
THIRD GRADERS IN WASHINGTON, DC
WILL EVER DRINK.
THE REASON THAT THE COCOA WAS SO
GOOD BEGINS WITH A RECESS FOR
THE RECORD BOOKS.
IT STARTED WITH A PROPOSAL MS.
FITZ PROMISED HER STUDENTS HOT
CHOCOLATE FOR EVERYONE IF SHE
MADE THE FULL COURT SHOT.
WATCH FOR YOURSELF.
[ CHEERING ]
MS. FITZ, AS SHE IS KNOWN, IS
KATHLEEN FITZPATRICK AND SHE
JOINS ME NOW.
MS. FITZ, 8 MILLION VIEWS, THE
LAST TIME I CHECKED.
I'M GOOD FOR A MILLION OF THEM
BECAUSE I CAN'T STOP WATCHING.
WHO'S MORE EXCITED, YOU OR THOSE
KIDS?
>> I THINK IT WAS A TIE BETWEEN
WHO WAS MORE EXCITED.
I THINK LIKE I WAS SHOCKED WHEN
IT WENT IN.
I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO GO IN BUT
AT THE SAME TIME I WAS HOPING,
BECAUSE I HAD PROMISED THEM HOT
CHOCOLATE.
SO IT HAD TO GO IN.
>> HEY, I KNOW YOU ARE THE PRIDE
OF
AM I RIGHT YOU'RE DOING A LITTLE
BIT OF A ROCKY DANCE THERE?
IS THAT A FILLY THING?
>> YOU KNOW, I GUESS YOU COULD
SAY IT'S A PHILLY THING.
I THINK IT'S JUST MY PURE
EXCITEMENT THAT I HAD MADE THE
SHOT.
>> YOU PLAYED BASKETBALL AT BOTH
ST. JOE'S AND RUTGERS.
DID YOU EVER HIT A BUZZER
BEATER?
>> I HAVE, YEAH.
>> WHICH WAS MORE EXCITING?
THIS ONE OR WHICHEVER ONE YOU'RE
THINKING OF?
>> I HAD -- I HAD A BUZZER
BUZZER BEATER AT RUTGERS, BUT I
THINK THIS WAS MORE EXCITING
THAN THE BUZZER BEATER AT
RUTGERS.
>> WHO IS REACHING OUT TO YOU?
I HAVE TO BELIEVE EVERYONE WHO
KNOWS YOU IS LIKE, OH, MY GOD, I
SAW THE VIDEO.
SO I ASSUME IT'S OLD FRIENDS AND
STUFF, BUT ANYBODY FAMOUS?
TELL ME WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
WORLD?
>> YOU KNOW, I AM NOT VERY GOOD
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE A TWITTER.
I HAVE AN INSTAGRAM, SO MY FEW
FRIENDS HAVE BEEN UPDATING ME
LIKE THESE PEOPLE ARE TWEETING
THIS, THESE PEOPLE ARE POSTING
IT.
SO I'VE BEEN HEARING IT FROM
LIKE MY CLOSEST FRIENDS AND
BROTHERS WHO ARE KEEPING ME
UPDATED ON EVERYTHING, BUT IT'S
JUST -- IT'S PRETTY CRAZY AND
SURREAL THAT IT'S GOTTEN TO THIS
POINT.
>> SO WHEN DID IT HIT YOU?
THIS WAS WHAT TWO DAYS AGO,
RIGHT?
I THINK YOU WERE ON BREAK TODAY.
TODAY'S THE FIRST DAY OF BREAK.
>> YEAH.
>> SO WHEN DID YOU REALIZE, OH,
MY GOD, THAT SHOT GNAT I MADE IS
NOW BEING VIEWED AROUND THE
PLANET?
>> THE SHOT HAPPENED ON FRIDAY,
AND I PROMISED THEM THE HOT
CHOCOLATE ON MONDAY.
AND THE VIDEO WAS POSTED ON OUR
SCHOOL'S ACCOUNT I THINK IT WAS
SUNDAY NIGHT.
SO IT REALLY LIKE MONDAY AND A
LITTLE TUESDAY IT WAS KIND OF
SLOW, AND THEN YESTERDAY IN
SCHOOL A LOT OF KIDS WERE SAYING
THINGS LIKE MS. FITZ, THIS VIDEO
HAS GONE VIRAL.
AND KIDS CAN EXAGGERATE LIKE NO
WAY, NO WAY, AND MY FRIENDS AND
FAMILY STARTED REACHING OUT LIKE
THIS THING IS VIRAL.
SO IT REALLY WAS YESTERDAY AND
THEN TODAY THAT IT REALLY HIT
ME, LIKE, OH, THIS THING HAS
GONE PRETTY VIRAL.
>> WELL, YOU PAID THE DEBT.
THAT WAS MY NEXT QUESTION.
I'M GLAD YOU'VE SETTLED IT.
AND ONE JUST TIME POINT, IF I
MIGHT.
YOU KNOW, WE LIVE IN DIFFICULT
TIMES FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH IS THE
PANDEMIC, AND THIS GAVE ME SUCH
JOY AND HAS GIVEN SO MANY
PEOPLE -- IT'S THE CRAZIEST
THING LIKE YOU SUNK THIS LONG
SHOT ON A PLAYGROUND IN
WASHINGTON, AND IT JUST TAKES MY
MIND OFF EVERYTHING ELSE I'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING HERE TONIGHT.
SO THANKS